[GUITAR STRUMMING]
CHRIS WILSON: Hey,
I'm Chris Wilson.
Like me, many of you probably
have a guitar or two tucked
away you like to
noodle around on.
Or like me, you have a basement
full of synthesizer and studio
gear.
But for years now,
I've been getting
more and more excited by
the powerful music software
available for desktop computers,
and lately even mobile devices.
Now, I can replicate vintage
synthesizer and processing
hardware and software, which
lets me stop filling up
my basement while draining
my checking account.
Well I'm here to tell you that
all that exciting software can
now come to the web platform
with an amazing open web
platform API called
the Web Audio API.
The Web Audio API was
designed for several purposes.
First of all, it's a great API
for building sound for gaming.
When we build
games, we need to be
able to make pew
pew pew sounds right
when our users hit the button.
You need to hear that
massive explosion right
as the screen lights
up, or whatever.
Now this was hard to do with
the HTML5 audio element, which
wasn't really designed
for precise timing,
multiple simultaneous
sounds, or memory management.
But the Web Audio
API also lets you
crack into the world of
digital audio in a big way.
You're in control
of the audio path
itself, with powerful but
easy to use processing nodes
to create effects like delay,
filtering, reverb, and more.
Now the Web Audio API lets
you create rich, multiply
layered effects by giving
you the primitives you need
to do the job, like delay nodes,
gain control, filtering, even
complex primitives
like convolution.
The goal isn't to give you
all the complex final effects
you could ever want.
It's to give you
all the primitives
you need to build
more complex effects.
When I first started playing
around with the Web Audio API,
I wanted to see just how far
I could take the processing
system.
So for a past Google I/O, I
wrote a vocoder application.
Now vocoding is a
fairly complex process.
It takes one sound source,
like me talking to you now,
and it chops it up
by frequency bands.
Next, it takes the volumes
in those bands over time
and it applies them dynamically
to the same frequency
bands in another sound,
usually a synthesizer sound.
(SYNTHESIZED) Now you'll be
able to sound like a robot.
You'll amaze your friends.
You can even change your
voice like a singing robot.
Do re mi fa so la ti do.
You can also use Web Audio to
create other audio processing
effects, like chorus effects,
or reverb, or pitch shifting.
I'm talking to you, Kent.
Or you can become Alvin,
Simon, or Theodore.
Should I give the rest
of my talk like this?
No, probably not.
To implement each of
these effects though,
I didn't write
JavaScript code that
acts directly on
the sound buffers.
I wrote code that combines
the processing nodes
that Web Audio gives me,
and it does all the work.
OK, so you can perform
real powerful processing
with Web Audio.
But where does that
sound source come from?
Where do you get started?
Well as I just
demonstrated, the sound
can come from the user's
audio inputs via WebRTC's
getUserMedia API, you
can hook the audio inputs
of your computer.
Sometimes, that's just the
microphone on your headset.
But you can also
have a pro quality
audio interface with a
killer axe plugged in.
[GUITAR RIFF]
Web audio can also hook any
media elements audio output,
so you can grab the audio output
from video or audio elements.
This can make it easy to do
just some basic processing,
like gain control or filtering,
on an audio element that
may be streaming
from the server.
But sound sources can also
come from audio samples
that you load through XML
HTTP request most likely.
And you can use Web Audio to
decode from MP3, wav, or OGG
format to a buffer.
When you play those
buffers back in Web Audio,
you can also change the
playback rate or detune them.
This makes it easy to take a
simple sample, like this one
I recorded of me
tapping a wine glass--
[CHIME]
--and turn it into a
playable musical voice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And finally, if you don't
want to use recorded sound,
you can use Web Audio's natively
implementing oscillators.
If you're an old
synthesizer nut like me,
you'll know the oscillators
create a basic waveform,
like a sine, square, saw
tooth, or triangle wave.
This makes it easy to produce
basic audio blips, bleeps,
and bloops.
Of course, oscillators also
make it completely possible
to build much richer
synthesizers without ever
loading a sound file, like
with this digitally replicated
analog synthesizer I built.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I tried to dig up a
keytar to play this live,
but I couldn't find one.
Now, oscillators aren't just
for building synthesizers.
They're also the key to
creating a lot of effects
and complex sounds.
Many effects, like the
very common chorus effect,
use oscillators
in the background.
Chorus is really just a delay
with a constantly varying delay
time.
That variation is caused
using an oscillator.
This kind of control is
possible because of Web Audio's
powerful, flexible audio
parameter and routing system.
Most parameters can be
controlled and scheduled
at the rate of the audio.
This makes for some
amazing effects.
For example, for those of
you who remember the '80s,
you can build FM synthesizers
similar to Yamaha's DX7
because you can modify
one oscillator's frequency
with another oscillator
at an audible frequency,
and that creates that classic
FM synth bell-like sound.
Working with the Web Audio
system's routing and parameter
schedule can be a little
daunting at first,
but think of it like
a queue of notes
that you need to keep full.
It's sort of like when you
sight read sheet music.
You need to look
ahead of where you
are to keep your
playing fingers primed.
The audio system is
busy under the hood
generating and processing
the sound stream
and keeping the sound
output happy by pushing
a continuous stream
of audio bits at it.
So really, the least you
can do is give it a little
heads up for what it will
need to be playing soon.
I wrote an article a while
ago about Web Audio scheduling
for HTML5 Rocks they can
help you better understand
this system.
And it can help teach you
to create rock solid timing
for musical applications, even
with JavaScript's not always
rock solid event
delivery timing.
This makes it so
you can easily build
drum machine and sequencing
applications that
keep a rock solid beat
while still responding
in near real time to
parameter changes.
One more critical piece to
building musical applications
is control.
In the music world,
nothing beats
having a real physical
instrument to finally control
your sound.
So we've been building
support for a standard called
the web MIDI API, that lets
music controllers like this,
or this, or even this get
plugged straight into the web
platform, so you can use them
for direct control of your web
applications.
This lets me have direct
physical immediate control
over these great
audio capabilities.
Now, the Web Audio API is
available on Chrome, Firefox,
and Safari today.
And Internet Explorer recently
began development as well.
But finally, I want to leave
you with one mind blowing
revelation.
All of these things
I've been talking about,
all of the incredible
power of the Web Audio API,
all of this works on the
mobile web as well with
modern mobile browsers.
iOS Safari and
Chrome for Android
both implement
the Web Audio API.
In fact, Chrome for
Android even has
an experimental
implementation of web MIDI,
so you can build amazing
web music applications
and take them with you
wherever the web goes.
So I hope I've
inspired you with some
of the things you can do with
the Web Audio and web MIDI
APIs.
Let's get out there
and make the web rock.